do you think President Trump's the right
leader during times like this to
continue challenging and pushing China I
think he is and the reason is is because
he's not a politician and you know what
I saw when I was at the White House is
look he just asked questions and and for
me you know if you're sometimes it is
the case that the best leader for a
situation is one that didn't grow up in
the system because then they can
question why the system is the way it is
they can ask questions and that they
don't get good answers then they can
make a decision that no other person
that grew up in that system would be
willing to make the hardest thing it is
for for people to do that that have been
in a bureaucracy for four decades is
really realize that they've been going
the wrong way for a long time and those
people are very hard to convince and and
so I would I would definitely look at
somebody that's outside the mainstream
you know to make the change now what I
see coming forward is there's a lot of
you know both Republican and Democratic
senators and congressmen and women that
are actually waking up and so I feel
much more comfortable about our future
in terms of the establishment because
they're going to be established during a
time when we recognize the threat and
they're gonna be they're gonna be more
wary of it you know but of course you
know the problem with with this current
system is term limits allows for all of
these people that have you know really
just been in the government all their
lives and haven't actually had to go and
and live out in society so I think in a
way because we don't have term limits we
have a disconnect between our
politicians that have been in office for
decades and the populace if this
continues past November you see Trump
still getting reelected I hope so
I'm confident that he will because I
think the people recognize that you know
we have to go different we have to go in
a different way which is by the way why
a socialist you know Bernie Sanders
almost won you know
the primary last time I think this time
you know the Democratic Party doesn't
really it's got a it's got it it's got
to come to grips with the fact that it's
got a significant percentage of its of
its base that doesn't agree with with by
donessa pick a big I mean AOC is going
after him hardcore she's not even
slowing down at all